a trek to the edge of ukraine where it
appears borders are being restored this
video released by ukraine's defense
ministry claims to show troops planting
a boundary marker at the country's
russian border in harkee region
president vladimir zelinsky thanks the
soldiers who have won back the territory
north of ukraine's second city a further
indication that russia is being forced
back
but the kremlin's attention is also
being diverted westward a day after
finland sweden formally confirmed its
intention to join nato leaving behind
200 years of neutrality in direct
response to russia's invasion of ukraine
as a nato member sweden would not only
strengthen its own security but also
contribute to enhanced security in the
baltic sea region
canada's foreign minister melanie jolie
met with european union foreign
ministers monday she says there is
cross-party support for canada to
quickly approve finland and sweden's
accession to nato the prime minister is
a very seized of the matter and we think
that it could take days for canada so
that's why we want to be one of the
first countries to do so
it may not be so simple in turkey it
wants both nordic nations to end their
support for the pkk kurdistan workers
party
turkey regards the kurdish separatist
group as a terrorist organization as
does canada and other allies
in moscow vladimir putin hosted a
meeting of nato's russian-led equivalent
the collective security treaty
organization it is a club of six former
soviet nations
putin told his counterparts the proposed
nato enlargement poses no threat to
their alliance but he warned that any
new nato infrastructure closer to russia
would provoke a response redmond shannon
global news london